what our research shows is that if you
look back in history the single most
important predictor of economic and
financial trouble is when a country
takes on too much debt over a short span
of time but if a country does that it's
bound to make bad loans it's bound to
make bad investment decisions because
there's no way that you can lend too
much money and find enough creditworthy
borrowers to make the right decisions
with that money over a short span of
time if a nation takes on too much debt
over a five year time horizon the next
five years typically tend to be very bad
for a country now first China is
concerned there is no developing country
in history which has taken on so much
debt over such a short span of time as
China has done in the after crisis era
that's why I remain so concerned about
China which is that China's debt as a
share of his GDP keeps going up over
time and today it's taking four dollars
of debt to create a dollar of GDP growth
in China in the first quarter that
number was as high as 6 to 1 at the peak
of the US housing bubble in 2008 it was
taking 3 dollars of debt to create a
dollar of GDP growth in the United
States so that how addicted to debt
China has become and why I remain so
worried about China's economic prospects
going forward so even though I was for
much of my working life in all of China
given how much China had achieved and
how well it had done on many of the
rules that I look at in the book from
its consistent zeal for reforms from the
way that its leadership would keep
changing and we energizing itself every
few years from the way that it made use
of its geography from the fact that its
demographics were quite favorable for
many years and how it relied so much on
a cheap currency to export its way to
prosperity but now my biggest concern is
that like all economic miracles China is
facing a point where the debt is so high
that
and miracle comes to an end
[Music]